hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt es mal ein video aus der
außerhalb der reihe denn ich habe ein
paar dinge die ich euch erzählen möchte
also theorie an also am samstag diesen
samstag am 19.12 werde ich im
globus-markt den wiesental also in
waghäusel wiesental eine signierstunde
machen und zwar dürfte da gerne
vorbeikommen und dann singe ich euch
gerne die bücher und ich habe auch
autogrammkarten mit dabei und zwar ist
es jetzt einfach so nochmal vor
weihnachten weil ich eben über den shop
in den bestellungen einfach die bücher
nicht signieren konnte weil es
organisatorisch und zeitlich nicht
möglich war
deswegen habt ihr einfach jetzt die
möglichkeit da hinzukommen das findet
statt von 15 bis 16.30 also das sagen
was einmal veranschlagt und da freue ich
mich natürlich wenn ihr kommen
aber wenn jetzt ganz weit weg wohnt
müsst ihr das natürlich nicht herkommen
ich bin ja auch nächstes jahr auf
manchen messen und dann können wir das
gerne auch dort machen man kann auch
bücher retten
genau da gibt's auch noch bücher den
aktuell sind sehr im shop leider
ausverkauft
was mich natürlich ziemlich überrascht
hat also ich bin er sei dankbar dafür
für das tolle positive feedback zum buch
und ich habe es auch wirklich sehr
gefreut
andererseits bin ich natürlich jetzt
traurig weil manches sich das buch seit
gewünscht hatten und ersetzt nicht vor
weihnachten bekommen haben
aber da habe ich mir einfach was anderes
überlegt und zwar könnt ihr da gerne
gutscheine im shop bestellen hier du
bist auch traurigkeit auch traurig und
zwar dürfte da gerne gutscheine
bestellen die habe ich alle handsigniert
also falls ihr das buch zu weihnachten
verschenken wolltet könnt ihr das eben
gerne mit dem gutschein tun und am 15
januar gibt es dann wieder die bücher im
shop die sind dann wieder erhältlich
wittmaack auch bücher mitbringen man
kann auch bücher natürlich mitbringen am
samstag falls ihr schon 1 habt und es
gerne unterschrieben haben wollt könnt
ihr das auch gerne mitbringen und ich
freue mich da wirklich sehr also samstag
19 12 10 15 bis 16.30 und die adresse
schreibe ich unten in die infobox ist
sich die hand brücker landstraße 4
glaube ich aber den globus kamen schnell
übersehen
und immer wenn jemand auf der straße
fragt woher stadt globus kann es euch
sagen die handlung
murat es auch mit dabei und jetzt
vielleicht noch ganz kurz zum shop wir
wurden ja wirklich sehr überrascht also
wir haben zwar schon damit gerechnet
dass der shop zusammenbricht und alles
möglich ist war dann auch wirklich so am
tag der veröffentlichung erster shop
zusammengebrochen
murat hat sich schon vorher gesehen aber
normalerweise liefern wir ziemlich
schnell zwischen 1 und 3 werktagen
aber dadurch dass es jetzt plötzlich so
viele bestellungen wegen dem buch waren
kamen halt manche ein bisschen bisher in
verzug das heißt wenn ihr jetzt fragen
zu euren paketen habt unser zu ihren
produkten habt könnt ihr gerne im shop
anrufen und dann schreibe ich euch auch
die telefonnummer in der infobox von 8
bis 18 uhr
genau von montag bis freitag und aber
bitte ruft nur an wenige wirklich nur
fragen zu den produkten bzw zu den
paketen habt denn sachen zu den rezepten
zum beispiel komplett beantworten dafür
bin ich da und das mache ich dann eben
per e mail oder in den kommentaren
also da könnt ihr euch gerne an den
schavan an die sabine wenden
es geht auf jeden fall schneller wir
werden jetzt eine e mail schreiben würde
telefonisch das einfach super schnell zu
regeln
und jetzt haben wir eigentlich nur noch
unseren gewinner des riesenslaloms den
habe ich jetzt schon verpackt na ja und
zwar habe ich ja denn es nutzt verlost
und zwar geht der an anika krebs auf
youtube von youtube genau über youtube
hat hast du geschrieben
du kannst mir gerne eine e mail an info
at least orten welt.de schreiben mit dem
betreff snoopy und dann schicken wir dir
also schreiben noch die adresse
natürlich mit rein und dann schicken wir
dir den riesen zloty zu herzlichen
glückwunsch und die karten uns weiter
gegen alle schon raus die habe ich alle
schriftlich benachrichtigt das war's
eigentlich glaube es war ein schnellstes
video
die fällt bestimmt noch was ein
ich habe mir 30 sekunden video gab es am
3d erfahrung also ich freu mich
geschickt übrigen ja bitte bringt nichts
mit am samstag also wirklich nichts sage
ich auch immer vorm essen wieder bringt
mir nichts mit kommt einfach selber und
bringt eure bücher zum beispiel mit eure
kinder können damit bringen die sehe ich
immer ganz gern star wars aufkleber
sonst genau die von der star wars
fotoaktion ja wie kostenlose seine
kosten laufen
ich freue mich auf euch samstagfrüh auch
am selben tag gibt es mit einer laser im
badischen in unserer heimat wieder zeit
habe das wird lustig das loch nix war's
ja versuche es hätte das video die länge
zu ziehen
alles da